بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
ونواصل
قصه
هجره النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من مكه الى
المدينه
وكان يرافقه ابو بكر الصديق رضي الله عنه
وكان
الدليل
عبد الله بن اريقط الليثي
العلماء اختلفوا
بعبد الله ابن اوريقه
بعضهم
ذكر انه اسلم
وهذا قول الذهب رحمه الله فانه ذكر عبد
الله ابن عريقه الليثي في عداد الصحابه
وبعض العلماء انكر ذلك
النووي عبد الغني المقدسي رحمهم الله
تعالى
وقد جزم ان عبد الله بن عريقه لم يسلم
فالله تعالى اعلم
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
واصل الطريق حتى وصل الى خيمه ام معبد
وخيمه ام معبد معروفه وكان الناس يمرون
بخيمتيها
وكانوا يشترون الطعام والشراب
ويتخذون عندها نزلا
في طريقهم وفي سفرهم
فمر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بام معبد
في قديد حيث مساكن خزاعه
وهي اخت خنيس بن خالد الخزاعي الذي روى
لنا هذه القصه
وهذه القصه تناقلها الرواه واصحاب السير
وقال عنها ابن كثير رحمه الله تعالى
وقصتها مشهوره مرويه من طرق يشد بعضها
بعضا وكما ذكرنا فيما سبق ان اسانيد
التاريخ واسانيد السيره
الشرط فيها اقل
واسهل من الشرط الذي يكون في حديث الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم
وهذه القصه تناقلها العلماء
وتناقلها السلف
رحمهم الله تعالى فاصبحت قصه مستفيضه
مشهوره
ولها طرق يشد بعضها بعضا
وقد جاء عن خالد بن خنيس الخزاعي الذي
يكون
ابن اخو ام معبد
كان صاحبًا لرسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
روى ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم حين
خرج من مكه
وخرج منها مهاجرا الى المدينه هو وابو بكر
رضي الله عنه
ومولى ابي بكر عامر ابن فهيره رضي الله
عنه
ودليلهما الليث عبد الله بن عريقه
مروا على خيمه ام معبد الخزاعيه
وكانت
برزه يعني كبيره السن
جلده
بمعنى انها قويه
احتدي يعني جالسه
محتبيه بفناء القبه
ثم تسقي وتطعم
او تكون في بفناء القبه ثم تسقي وتطعم
الماره
فسالوها لحما وتمرا ليشتروه منها فلم
يصيبوا عندها شيئا من ذلك وكان القوم
مرلين
مسنتين يعني في حاله فقر وفي حاله قله
فنظر رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم الى
شاه في كسر في كسر الخيمه
فقال ما هذه الشاه يا ام معبد
قالت خلفها الجاهد عن الغنم يعني طلع ابو
معبد معه الغنم
وترك هذه خلفها من الجهد يعني انها ضعيفه
هزيله ما تستطيع انها تخرج حتى
مع الراعي
فقال هل بها من لبن
قالت هي اجهد من ذلك يعني هذه بعيده عن
اللبن هذه حتى
على قيد الموت
قال اتاذنين ان احلبها قالت بلى بابي انت
وامي نعم ان رايت بها حلبا فحلبها
فدعا بها رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فمسح بيده ضرعها
وسمى الله عز وجل
ودعا لها في شاتها
فتفاجت عليه ودرت واجترت ودعا باناء يربض
الرهط
يربط الرهط يعني الجماعه لو شربوا من هذا
الاناء على حجمه
يرتو
فحلب فيها فجا حتى علاه البهاء
الرغوه ثم سقاها حتى رويت
وسقى اصحابه
حتى رووا
وشرب اخرهم ثم اراضوا
ثم حلب فيها ثانيا بعد بدء حتى ملا الاناء
ثم غادره عندها ثم بايعها وارتحلوا عنها
يعني حلب لها مره اخرى زادا لي
اهل البيت ثم بايعها
على الاسلام وارتحلوا عنها
فقل ما لبثت حتى جاء زوجها ابو معبد يسوق
اعنزا عجافا عجافا يعني
صغار هزيلات كانوا في سنه يعني كانوا في
قحط
يتساوكنا هزلا ضحى
مخهن قليل المخ يعني الذي يكون في العظم
قليل وهذه
اعنز كانت هزيله فلما راى ابو معبد اللبن
عجب
قال من اين من اين لك هذا اللبن يا ام
معبد والشاه كذا وكذا
فاخبرت له
واخبرته القصه
مر بنا فلان من الناس ثم وصفت
ام معبد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
لزوجها
فقالت رايت رجلا ظاهرا الوضاءه
ظاهر الوضاءه يعني النظافه
ابلج الوجه
ابلج الوجه يعني مشرق
حسن الخلق او حسن الخلق
الهما صحيح
لم تعبه نحله
يعني من النحول
ولم تزري به صعله
صعله يعني صغر الراس
وسيم فهو صلى الله عليه وسلم موصوف سبحان
الله بالوسط في كل شيء
موصوف في الطول بين الطويل والقصير طوله
متوسط
وموصوف عليه الصلاه والسلام
بين
السمره
والبياض متوسط بينهما وهكذا قالت وسيم في
عينيه دعج
والدعج هو شده سواد العين
قالت وفي اشفاره وطف
الاشفار يعني في شعر اجفانه طول صلى الله
عليه وسلم
وفي صوته صهل
كالبوحه وهو الا يكون حاد الصوت يعني صوت
او ليس رفيعا
وانما فيه ايش
فيه
نوع من البحه صلى الله عليه وسلم
وفي عنقه سطع
يعني طويل العنق
وفي لحيته كثافه
ازج يعني دقيق شعر الحاجبين مع طولهما
اقرن
اي متصل ما بين الحاجبين من الشعر او
مقرون الحاجبين الحاجبان
بينهما اتصال
ان صمت فعليه الوقار وان تكلم سما وعلاه
البهاء
اجمل الناس
وابهاهم من بعيد
واحلاهم واحسنهم من قريب
حلو المنطق
فصل فصل يعني كلامه واضح ما فيه غمغمه ما
في لف الكلام دغري وفصل
لا هذر ولا نذر
يعني صلى الله عليه وسلم الهذر من الكلام
ما لا فائده فيه
والنذر هو القليل الذي
لا يشبع المستمع
لا هو كلام كثير زياده عن المفروض ولا اقل
عن ما يفيد المستمع
كان منطقه خرزات نظم يتحذرنا
الذي يجلس اليه ويستمع الى كلامه
حتى غير المسلم يريد ان يحفظ جميع ما يقول
صلى الله عليه وسلم
لذلك قالت كان منطقه خرزات
خرزات نضمن يتحدرن
ربع الرابع هو المتوسط لا بالطويل ولا
بالقصير
لا باس من طول يعني مش مفرط في طوله حتى
يكون بارزا بروزا
قبيحا بين الناس ولا تقتحمه العين من قصر
غصن بين غصنين
فهو انظر الثلاثه منظره
الاصحاب الثلاث الذين كانوا معه
فهو كان
انظر الثلاثه منظرا يعني
منفرد عنهما في النضاره
لمعان يعني
وشروق الوجه
واحسنهم قدرا له رفقاء
يحفون به مهتمين فيه واضح انه انتباههم
وذهنهم متسلط على النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ان قال استمعوا لقوله
وان امر تبادروا الى امره
محفوذ
محفوظ يعني مخدوم
محشود
يعني الناس يجتمعون عليه
لا عابس ولا مفند العابس يعني الذي
يعبس اذا اذا ارتاح وجهه وعاد الوجه الى
العاده لا يعود الى العبس
ولا مفند
يعني ليس منسوبا الى الجاهل وقله العقل
صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال ابو معبد هو والله صاحب قريش صاحب
قريش يعني الذي سمعنا خبره من قريش
والذي كان في
هذا الامر الذي استفاض عن قريش في ذاك
الزمن فقال هو والله صاحب قريش الذي ذكر
لنا من امره ما ذكر بمكه ولقد هممت ان
اصحبه ولا افعل نائم ان وجدت الى ذلك
سبيلا
لما بعد ان مر من عند
قباب امي معبد
ومن خزاعه
من اجل انه عما طريقه على اعدائه
فكان
الذي يخرج
بزاد ابو بكر
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هي
هي اسماء بنت ابي بكر واخت عائشه لابيها
ولذلك يقال لها
ذات النطاقين النطاق هو المربط
فكان المراه عاده لها
لها هذا الشيء يعني لها واحد من هذه
المرابط على الخصر
فهي كانت لها
نطاقان نطاق فيه زاد النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ونطاق لنفسها فاشتهر هذا الاسم عنها او
هذا اللقب او معروف عن اسماء رضي الله
عنها ويقال لها
ذات النطاقين كما في صحيح البخاري
فما عرفوا
الى اين اتجه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
فسخر الله سبحانه وتعالى
من الجن او من الملائكه الامر غير واضح
من هو صاحب صوت وشعر يمر بين دور اهل مكه
دخل مكه وهو يرفع صوته حتى خرج منها
يقول فاصبح صوت بمكه عاليه يسمعون الصوت
ولا يدرون من صاحبه
احتمال يكون من الجن
احتمال يكون من الملائكه
وهذا الصوت يقول
يقول شعرا
والعرب في ذاك الزمن كانوا اذا سمعوا
الشعر حفظوه
احفظوون الشعر
حفظا متقنا بعضهم يحفظ بعد مره بعضهم بعد
مرتين لكن حفظهم كان
كان يعني دقيقا وكانوا يحفظون
فقال هذا الصوت
جاز الله رب الناس خير جزاءه رفيقين قال
خيمتي امي معبدي قال يعني
من القيل والارتياح
وقت القيلوله
هما نزل بالبر ثم تروحا فقد فاز من امسى
رفيق محمدي
فيالي قصي ما زوى الله عنكم به من فعال لا
تجاره
ليهن بني كعب مكان فتاتهم
ومقعدها للمؤمنين بمرصده سلوا اختكم عن
شاتها وانائها يعني ام معبد
فانكم ان تسالوا الشاه تشهدي
يعني حتى الشات
دهاها بشاه حائل فتحلبت عليه عليه صريحا
ضره الشاه مزبده فغادرها
رهنا لديها لحالب يرددها في مصدر ثم موردي
وهذا هذه القصه وهذه التفاصيل
مذكوره عند الطبران في الكبير
ومذكوره عند الهيثمي في مجمع الزوائد
وهكذا يعني اسانيد كما قال ابن كثير يشد
بعضها بعضه
وقد مر بنا طرف من
قصه سراقه ابن مالك
رضي الله عنه وسراقه
قيل انه اسلم يوم فتح مكه
وهذا مروي في صحيح البخاري
وعاش الى فتح
عمر رضي الله عنه لفارس
وله قصه مع ذلك
يقول المؤلف اعلنت قريش في نوادي مكه انه
من ياتي بالنبي حيا او ميتا فله مائه ناقه
وانتشر هذا الخبر عند قبائل الاعراب الذين
في ضواحي مكه
وطمع سراقه ابن مالك ابن جحش في نيل الكسب
الذي اعدته قريش لمن ياتي برسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم
فاجهد نفسه لينال ذلك ولكن الله بقدرته
التي لا يغلبها غالب جعله يرجع مدافعا عن
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم بعدما كان
جاهدا عليه خرج ليقبض عليه وعاد مدافعا عن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول ابن
شهاب ابن شهاب الزهري معروف يقول واخبرني
عبد الرحمن بن مالك المدلجي يقال مدلج
ومدلج ومدلج يعني لغات في
بني مدلج او مدلج
وهو ابن اخي سراق ابن مالك ابن جحشم ان
اباه اخبره انه سمع صراخ ابن جحش يقول
جاءنا رسل كفار قريش يجعلون في رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم وابي بكر ديه كل واحد
منهما لمن قتله او اسره فبينما انا جالس
في مجلس من مجالس قوم بني مدلج اذ اقبل
رجل منهم حتى قام علينا ونحن جلوس فقال يا
سراقه اني قد رايت انفا اسوده بالساحل
اسود جمع قله في اللغه السويده يعني
الاشخاص رايتهم
يسافرون قله دون التسعه
اراها محمدا واصحابه قال سراقه فعرفت
انهم هم فقلت له انهم ليسوا بهم ولكنك
رايت فلانا وفلولانا انطلقوا باعيننا ثم
لبثت في المجلس ساعه يعني وقتا ثم قمت
فدخلت فامرت جاريتي ان تخرج بفرشي وهو من
ورائي اكمه
فتحبسها علي
واخذت رمحي فخرجت به من ظهر البيت
فخططت بزجه الارض يعني لا يريد ان يرفع
الرمح حتى لا يظهر من وراء الاكمه الرمح
وخفضت عاليه حتى اتيت فرسي فركبتها
فرفعتها اي اسرعت بها السير
تقرب بي حتى دنوت منهم
فعثرت بي فرسى فخررت عنها فقمت فاهويت
بيدي الى كنانتي
فاستخرجت منها الازلام ذكرنا فيما مضى
الازلام ما هي
وهذه الازلام لمن لم يسمع
في
الجلسه السابقه الازلام
جمع زلم وهي نوع من
نوع من الشرك في كتاب الله وقد سمى الله
سبحانه وتعالى الازلام رجسا فقال يا ايها
الذين امنوا انما الخمر والميسر والانصاب
والازلام ريجيسون من عمل الشيطان فاجتنبوه
لعلكم تفلحون
هذه الازلام
كانوا يقدسونها وكانوا يقدسون
ما
يتوصلون اليه عن طريق الازلام هي عباره عن
خشبات او اسهم مكتوب على وحده منها مكتوب
افعل والثاني لا تفعل وثالث هيك يكون
ثلاثه او يكون خمسه او عشره كم يكون
ثم
يجعلونها في كنانه
ويفكر او يحكي الموضوع اللي بده يستخير
فيه
فيخرج هذه الازلام فاذا جاء افعل فعل اذا
جاء لا تفعل
احجم
والله عز وجل
ابدلنا بالازلام
صلاه الاستخاره فنحن نستخير الله وقال
جابر رضي الله عنه كما في الصحيح كان رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يعلمنا الاستخاره
كما يعلمنا
الايه من القران
فعلمنا صلى الله عليه وسلم ان نقوم
ونستخير الله سبحانه وتعالى
والله عز وجل
امرنا ان نستشير اهل الخبره وشاورهم في
الامر فاذا عزمت فتوكل على الله
فهذه الازلام نوع من الشرك وهذا شيء منتشر
بين الناس
وهذا يختلف
عن التساهم هذا شيء اخر يعني
يعني مثلا
يفعلوا كثير من المسلمين
يفعلون ما يقال له الاستفتاح مثلا
عنده شيء في باله او متردد في مساله او ما
يعرف ماذا يفعل فياخذ المصحف ويفتحه
ويضع اصبعه
فما وقع عليه اصبعه يقول هذا ايش هذه
الايه لي في هذا الموضوع هذا نوع الحاقه
والعلماء بحكم الازلام هذا امر لا يجوز
الانسان يستخير الله سبحانه وتعالى
يقول
فاستخرت منها الازلام
فاستقسمت بها
اضرهم ام لا فخرج الذي اكرهه
يعني خرج لا تفعل
فركبت فرسي
وعصيت الازلام
تقرب بي حتى اذا سمعت قراءه رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم وهو لا يلتفت وابو بكر
يكثر الالتفات يعني خوفا على النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
ساخت يد الفرس في الارض
حتى بلغت الركبتين فخضرت عنها ثم زجرتها
يعني كان على الفرس
فنهضت فلم تكد تخرج يديها فلما استويت
فلما استوت قائمه اذا
لاثر يديها عثان ساطع في السماء مثل
الدخان سبحان الله
فاستقسمت بالازلام فخرج الذي اكره
فناديتهم بالامان
فوقفوا فركبت فارسي حتى جئتهم ووقع في
نفسي حين لقيت ما لقيت من الحبس عنهم
ان سيظهر او سيظهر امر رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم
هذه المسائل وهذه الاشياء لم تكن صدفه
وانما هذا الرجل سينصره الله وهو صادق
فيما يقول
ولكنه لم يسلم حين ذاك وانما تاخر اسلامه
فقلت له ان قوم قط جعلوا فيك الديه
واخبرتهم اخبار ما يريد الناس بهم
وعرضت عليهم الزاد والمتاع
ولم يسالاني الا ان قال
اخفي عنا ما نحتاج منك لا زاد ولا مال ولا
شيء وانما الذي نحتاج ان تعمي علينا او
تعمي على اعدائنا الطريق الذي نحن فيه
فقال اخفي عنا فسالت ان يكتب لي كتاب امن
يعني حين ان يظهرك الله اريد ان اتي بهذا
الكتاب يعني الكتاب يعني المكتوب ويكون
هذا
امان لي فامر عامر بن فهيره فكتب في
رقعه من ادم ثم مضى رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم
وكان مما اشتهر عند الناس من امر سراقه ما
ذكره ابن عبد البر وابن حجر وغيرهما قال
ابن عبد البر
روى سفيان ابن عيينه عن ابي موسى عن الحسن
ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
لسراقه ابن مالك كيف بك اذا لبست سوى ري
كسرى كسرى هذا لقب ليس اسما هذا لقب مثل
قيصر كسره يكون عظيم فارس قيصر عظيم الروم
كذلك فرعون هذا لقب
وكذلك النجاشي هذا لعظيم الحبشه
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول لسراقه وهذه من دلائل النبوه
قال كيف بك اذا لبست سوى ري كسره يعني
جماعه
ما عندهم الزاد ما عندهم الطعام
يعيشون حياه متواضعه جدا
ويمرون باحوال صعبه جدا
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في هذه الاحوال
المحيطه بهم يقول لسراق كيف بك اذا لبست
سواريه كسره يعني شيء
صعب يتصوره الانسان
فهو قال كيف بك اذا لبست سوى ري كسره قال
فلما اتي عمر بسواري كسرى
ومنطقه وتاجه
السواري على اليدين والمنطقه والتاج
دعا سراقه ابن مالك
فالبسه اياها وكان سراق رجلا ازب كثير شعر
الساعدين
الازب في لغه العرب هو صاحب الشعر الكثيف
الكثير
فايديه فيه شعر شديد يعني فوق العاده فكان
يستحي انه يوري الناس ايديه
ولكن عمر رضي الله عنه
امر سراقه ان يرفع يديه وقال له ارفع يديك
فقال الله اكبر الحمد لله الذي
سلباهما كسر ابنه هرمز ورفع بها عمر صوته
يقول الحمد لله الذي سلبهما كسرى ابن هرمز
الذي كان يقول انا رب الناس
والبسهما سراقه ابن مالك ابن جعشم اعرابيا
من بني مدلج
تلك الايام نداولها بين الناس سبحان الله
اهل
الماده واهل العده والعده واهل القوه
صعب عليهم انهم يتصوروا ان يذهب هذا
هذا الامر عنهم
وان يعودوا صغارا بين يدي الله سبحانه
وتعالى
وهذا من اسباب الكفر هذا الرجل الذي دخل
جنته وهو ظالم لنفسه قال ما اظن انت بيد
هذه ابدا وما اظن الساعه قائمه يعني لما
دخل جنته
راى
من كثافه الجنه
وتلك الجنه اتت اكلها ولم تظلم منه شيئا
يعني كد ما اخذت منها
فانها لا تكاد
تنقص منها
فهذا يغر صاحبه
الذي لا يؤمن بعظمه الله سبحانه وتعالى
فهذا ان غر ان غرب استمكانه في الدنيا لكن
الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول وتلك الايام
نداولها بين الناس وفي يوم وليله ممكن
الواحد يغنى والفقير الفقير يغني والغني
يفقر والعكس في يوم في ليله
وهذا امر سيظهر في اخر الزمان يكثر هذا
الامر
في بعض ما ذكر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
من احوال اخر الزمان
ان الغنى
يكون سريعا
والفقر كذلك بعض الناس يكون فقير
جاي من سلاله فقيره فما
يدري الا وقد غني في يوم وليله هكذا
وهذا بعض ما ذكره العلماء في قول النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم وان تلد الامه ربتها
من معاني هذه
الروايه ما ذكرته
فعلى كل حال
كسره كان يقول وانا رب الناس
وكان يظن ان لن يحور
الله عز وجل يقول انه كان في اهله
مسرورا انه ظن ان لن يحور
يحور يعني يعود الى الضعف
والفقر
والقله والحاجه الى الله سبحانه وتعالى
بعد ان
استنت قواه
فقال عمر رضي الله عنه لما البس سراقه بن
مالك
سواري كسره ومنطقته وتاجه
قال ارفع يديك
وقال الله اكبر الحمد لله الذي سلبهما كسر
بن هرمز
الذي كان يقول انا رب الناس والبسهما
سراقه ابن مالك ابن جحشم اعرابي من بني
مدلج ورفع بها عمر صوته ثم اركب سراقه
وطوف به المدينه والناس حوله وهو يرفع
عقييرته مرددا قول الفاروق الله اكبر
الحمد لله الذي سلبهما كسر بن هرمز
والبسهما سراقه ابن جعشم اعربيا من بني
مدلج
يقول المؤلف كان سراقه في بدايه امره يريد
القبض على رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وتسليمه لزعماء مكه
لينال 100 ناقه واذا بالامور تنقلب راسا
على عقب
ويصبح يرد الطلب عن رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم
فجعل لا يلقى احدا من الطلب الا رده قائلا
كفيتم هذا الوجه
فلما اطمئن الى ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم وصل الى المدينه المنوره جعل سراق
يقص ما كان من قصته وقصه فرسه واشتهر هذا
عنه
وتناقلته الالسنه حتى امتلات به نوادي مكه
فخاف رؤساء قريشا يكون ذلك سببا لاسلام
بعض اهل مكه
وكان سراقه امير بني مدلج ورئيسهم
فكتب ابو جهل اليهم بني مدلج اني اخاف
سفيهكم سراقه مستغون لنصر محمد
عليك عليكم به الا يفرق جمعكم فيصبح شتى
بعد عز وسؤدد
فارادوا ان
ارادوا الناس ان ينتهوا عن هذه القصه لان
هذه القصه هي دليل على نبوه النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم وعلى انه موسى يمكن في
الارض
فكري هو ان يشتهر ان يشتهر هذا
وابو جاهل يقول عن سراقه ويقول بني مدلج
اني اخاف سفيهاكم
عاد سراقه كان من اعقلهم وكان من عظماء
بني مدلج لكن
فقال هذا وكتب ابو جهل اليهم بني مدلج اني
اخاف سفيهكم مدرج او مدلج كما ذكرنا سراقه
مستغون لنصر محمد عليكم به الا يفرق جمعكم
فيصبح شتى بعد عز وسؤدد
فقال سراق يرد على ابي جاهل ابا حكمي ابا
حكم اللاتي لو كنت شاهدا لامر جوادي اذ
تسيق قوائمه
عجبت ولم تشكك بان محمدا رسول ببرهان فمن
ذا يقاومه عليك فكف القوم عنه فانني ارى
امره يوما ستبدو معالمه بامر تود الناس
فيه باسرهم بان جميع الناس طرا مسالمه
وكان الذي توقعه
سراقه على رغم انوف اعداء النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
هاتان قصتان مشهورتان مستفيضتان عن هجره
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وقد وقعت امور
اخرى
في طريقه ولكن هذه
ولكن هاتين الوقعتين والقصتين مشهورتان
معروفتان صحيحه الاسناد
وكثير مما يذكر في هذا الباب في باب
السيره يعني مثلا لو الانسان اخذ
لو اخذ البدايه والنهايه لابن كثير او لو
اخذ سيره ابن هشام مثلا
سيقرا
اقوالا وقصصا وروايات هي في الحقيقه فيها
ضعف وفي الحقيقه
بالنسبه الى
اسانيد الحديث النبوي فانها
تكون فيها انقطاع وتكون فيها ارسال وهكذا
لكن هذا لا يضرها ان شاء الله لان الاحكام
لا تستنبط من
السيره
فمثلا قصه العنكبوت
هل هذه قصه صحيحه او لا هي قصه ما الها
اسناد يذكرها اهل السيره وبس ما الها
اسناد ما نعرف لانه لان كتاب
ابن اسحاق محمد ابن اسحاق رحمه الله في
السيره الذي
سيره ابن هشام هو مختصره وتهذيبه مفقود
مفقود من
زمن الذهبي رحمه الله فما نستطيع نطلع على
هذه الاسانيد لكن من ذكرها من العلماء
ذكرها استئناسا هل هي ممكنه ممكنه هل
استفاضت استفاضت هل نستطيع ان نردها لا
اذا لا يمررونها
وليس
يؤخذ من هذه القصص
احكام فقهيه مثلا فهذه الاحكام لابد ان
تنبني على اسس ثابته من نصوص القران ومن
صحيح سنه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
فهذه الروايات يحكيها العلماء ما ينبغي
التشدد فيها هي تذكر وتروى وممكنه ومحتمله
والروايات الاخرى التي ينبني عليها احكام
فان اسناد هذه الروايات لابد ان تكون
ثابته لانه الحين بنستنبط من
حكم الله سبحانه وتعالى ولكن في هذه
القصاص وهذه الاشياء كذلك فيها سنيد
التفسير كذلك في اسانيد الغزوات
يذكر في تاريخ الاسلام اشياء كثيره
لا باس بها ان تذكر ان شاء الله تعالى ولا
ينبغي التشدد فيها نكتفي بهذا القدر والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين